guys need to
control their emotions women get a free
pass they get a free pass and a lot of
stuff right you know the gals can have
emotional outbursts and Hissy Fits and
um not many people will bat an eye you
know for being honest
um guys you don't get the same
privileges right you've got to have some
control
um in some cases it's it's almost
celebrated when women have you know
outburst and Hissy Fits and it's the
reason why we have you know Cairns and
stuff like that it's it's people losing
control of their emotions
um
I don't know
like where do I even begin with this
like this is a lifelong journey for me
too you know I've always had a
short fuse especially when I was younger
I mean some
you watch any of my stuff you'd be like
rich is a short fuse dude you know he
can he can snap yeah you know Rich snaps
um Rich has snapped you know let's be
honest but um yeah like
I remember when I was young like we used
to ride in uh packs you know we were on
our motorcycles and
um the thing with
um you know having a motorcycle at that
age and being young and thinking that
you're Invincible you tend to Ride Hard
everywhere you go some might say it's
aggressive
um and then there's a lot of people that
just aren't paying attention because
they don't expect you know something
that this that's a little bit bigger
than a bicycle with a guy on it to come
flying by them at like Mach 3.
um they don't check their blind spots
when they make turns or anything like
that and one of the things that used to
enrage me I mean it enraged everybody in
my crew you know at the same time but it
used to arrange me when
um they would put your life at risk
right
a lot of people think that motorcyclists
are just um
you know dangerous or they take uh
great risks that are unnecessary and
that's not really true if everybody on
the road rode a motorcycle
it would be a lot safer for those that
ride the motorcycles I'll you know just
say that because people only drive in a
dangerous way to others on the road when
they are driving in a [__] cage let's
just put it that way because because you
feel like you're safe like you're
Invincible that's what that's why people
like SUVs and stuff like that and you
know I was
you know I threw my um motorcycle jacket
the other day and we used to keep um
spark plugs broken spark plugs and our
motorcycle jacket because the theory was
or this is what we were told anyway is
um you know you whip those at a car
window and they'll go right through it
all right it'll break the window
um definitely caused some damage so that
so that would be the lesson that
motorcyclists would teach
um bad Automotive drivers
I never had to use one personally
um but I was told that's what they were
good for but you know you get cut off
like I had my life
um you know putting up you know put in a
position where I was going on a road
once and this guy just made a UE he
didn't even check his shoulder or
nothing and I was you know accelerating
up just did a u and I had to slam longer
breaks did a stop he came up on the
front wheel almost went over his car and
he just kept going and took off and that
was it didn't even stop the look
right
and you lose it you know and you know
scenarios like that like you get mad you
get really mad right
um
but it's you know it's part of life you
know things are going to disappoint you
you are going to get mad at [__] you
know the like
I've said that anger is a legitimate
response in the face of an injustice
fact of life
um somebody puts your life at risk you
can get mad
um you know guys that invest into a
relationship get married you know even
and she goes and uh you know cheats on
him sometimes shoots on him multiple
times get mad I get it right but where
where it goes into difficult territories
where you lose control of your emotions
where you completely snap this is where
guys will go out and they'll and they'll
say and do and run their mouths in such
a way that it gets them in trouble with
the law okay I've seen it happen before
I've seen it happen to friends even
recently
um you know there's a time and a place
for certain things but you also have to
know when to walk away and just shut the
[__] up right and not and not get into a
confrontation
um
I understand the appeal to it because
the way of men is a way of gang you know
and you know when you're together with
your boys
um things can escalate sometimes
make sure you have good boys you know if
that's the way that you're going to roll
um but getting emotional is just it
ain't it ain't it ain't ever going to
serve you man it ain't ever going to do
you any good
I'm I'm just gonna grab this chapter
from my book I mean I know some of you
guys have read it the unplugged Alpha is
on Amazon
um I'll just grab the audible chapter
and I'll play it through I think it's a
nine minute chapter and I'll I'll speed
it up so it's like 1.3 times speed or
something like that because I want you
to hear
um what I had written about I'll kind of
build on that and expand on it
all right
um I'm plugged out uh chapter so the
title of this chapter is chapter nine
and uh it's manage the F's you give I
spell it out in full of course I I'm not
supposed to swear on the YouTubes early
on in the show or swear as little as
possible apparently that's that's the
gig that's the way things work
all right so let me just hit play on
this it's just a quick eight minutes in
a bit at the speed so let me know if you
have any problems hearing it uh in the
chat but here we go
manage the [__] you give
when I was young we played a lot of
player versus player video games there
was a popular one called Mortal Kombat
and they all operated on the same
concept you started with 100 on your
life bar and as you battle you should
produce your life until it was zero
percent and you died
life isn't much different essentially
it's about a ticket all day long gaining
our energy attention and resources until
we hit zero unfortunately most people
don't value The energy they give away
and they freely dispose it like it's an
unlimited resource and this is a big
mistake
many people today see the barrage of
hate I get for the truth I reveal in my
videos and they ask me how often my
response is you need to learn to give
the girl [__]
we all by Design have a limited
relatively for our daily lives
everything we do takes time and
resources our job kids friends events
partners and even the small things like
when I found one's going to kill a
spider in the bathroom
I refer to the energy that you can spend
as the [__] you can give therefore it's
included upon you as a man of vision and
purpose to manage everything wisely
we are the masters of our lives so we
have the privilege of deciding where we
want to dispense those limited amounts
of [__] on only we get to choose what
is truly fuckworthy in our lives
when you drive to work and the [__]
and the BMW Cuts you off you often
choose to allocate those [__] to being
frustrated
and saving those [__] for something
else
when a co-worker makes a disparaging
comment because you won't donate 10
Donna and accounting's fundraiser you
can sense those [__] and comment back
with your feelings or you can go about
your business at a zero Flex given kind
of way and ignore her underhanded
comment
to truly manage your Flex you must first
Master self-control
self-control you know the [__] and
the BMW who doesn't signal and cuts you
off you have two choices number one
throw a tantrum in your car wave your
middle finger about Flash your high
beams before accelerating up to his
bumper giving away some of your limited
[__] in the process
number two utilize self-control and
preserve your [__] for something more
fuckworthy and do nothing
option one burns up some of your limited
[__] for the day and also applies
stress to your body cortisol this
hormone is released in your body when
somebody gets on your skin making it
catabolic whereas there's nothing
ultimately mastering self-control and
your emotion matters
those who are World Class of their craft
and pursue Excellence are incredibly
careful about managing their time energy
and resources ultimately you can't
become the best version of yourself if
you're constantly reacting your energy
to things the energy don't bring you
closer to your goals passions and dreams
where awareness goes energy flows down
to Pani
while this might seem like a simple
notion this idea was profound for me I
met Don dapani a monk during his dinner
event in Toronto where he was booked as
a keynote speaker
he's down there before us Lex crossed on
the floor and full mug Barb with beads
and three white lines painted on his
forehead
he was in a white character
entrepreneurs are running successful
multi-million dollar businesses to
devote them to us as a Hindu priest with
an Australian accent we finished 10
years in a Paul's period in Hawaii
entrepreneurs are notoriously prone to
distractions and many have varying
degrees of attention deficit disorder or
add they're like herding cats this monk
was there to help entrepreneurs under
the motion of what energy vampires are
and how to manage their awareness to be
more
awareness you explain is like a glowing
ball of Light which was around your head
and when it comes to a particular area
of the mind then that area is lit up
which is where your energy then flows so
if awareness goes to a happy area of the
mind and it's where your energy is
flowing and if energy is Flowing to the
Happy area of the mind and it is also
strengthening this area
in order to manage and the biggest
threat from all places or things that
are energy vampires these are usually
people that will take up your time drain
your energy leave you feeling exhausted
from your encounter with them
keyword here is exhausted after your
encounter for more on that search for
how to deal with energy vampires on my
YouTube channel
mastering self-control
so how do you master self-control
self-control is perhaps the most
powerful skill you can develop that will
help you master a better life when you
learn how to manage your [__] and walk
away from energy vampires you exercise
self-control and start preserving your
flux for truly fuckworthy things that
make you happy in life how do you know
if something is fuckworthy simple if the
dispensing you or your loved one's lives
better but it's usually worth dispensing
precious Flex on some might argue that
this is a selfish or unkind way to
navigate life I propose that you
reevaluate how serious you are about
managing your energy if this is violated
by my statement above
if the dispensive set fluctuates you or
your problems
let me give you a perfect example I
didn't several other ones and one of her
core batches was dinner parties she
would invite guests that were exhausting
to be around my date had one friend that
would berate criticize and judge
everyone including her husband her
friend was a typical stay-at-home soccer
mom with teenage kids who also had an
exceedingly high opinion of herself
however she was nothing more than obese
middle-aged woman expecting people to
agree with her world view she was in
fact an energy vampire meaning that
being around her was an emotionally
draining experience
simply plot there was no benefit to
being in the same room as her I knew
that she set a terrible example of what
an adult woman should be I knew I didn't
want to have my daughter around that
energy after I received a second invite
and another dinner party I decline that
as you expect declining the offer
offended my girlfriend she tried to
create an argument out of it I simply
didn't take part thank you for the
invite and end of the call we didn't
talk for a few days and she called me
after the dinner event to apologize
you see when you exercise self-control
you manage your flux better when you
become aware of who is an energy vampire
in your life you will be forced to make
choices that may offend some people
guess what that's okay
a man that is on his purpose in life
will inevitably rub some people the
wrong way remember if you value your
flux's unlimited resource you will only
dispense it for things that are truly
fuckworthy
self-control
it's my belief that self-control is like
a muscle and the more you work it the
stronger it gets one of the simplest
ways to strengthen that self-control
muscle is to do things that are
physically difficult or challenging if
you're looking for a task to improve
your self-control then taking a cold
shower for most people's heart
especially if you had access to hot
water all your life hot water is a
modern luxury but for millions of years
we've been bathing in icy lakes and
rivers to take a cold shower requires
self-control but most people don't have
the ability to do something basic like
stand in uncomfortably cold water in the
shower I urge you to start taking cold
showers for the following reasons it
strengthens your self-control it also
offers the following health benefits
reduces brain fog and improve focus
improve circulation keep skin and hair
healthy strengthens the immunity system
improves energy and well-being improves
metabolic abilities
do you want to improve your self-control
and learn manage your flexible and start
by doing something as simple as taking
cold showers it's easy to understand
simple to execute on but takes
discipline and willpower to build
I was speaking at a conference and
closed off my talk speaking about
managing your [__] and somebody asking
the audience how they felt anxiety over
dispensing their [__] and how to
reserve them better the bottom line is
this if you value your [__] as a
resource that has a limit to it then you
will only allocate your limited [__]
towards matters that truly deserve your
[__]
the cold hard truth never yeah the
energy that you begin with every day and
the last few seconds is just a
conclusion but I think I've just
destroyed my uh monetization on this
video for tonight because the whole
thing was just all F this and f that so
anyway let's just [__] carry on
um
yeah so again if you haven't got the
book get it get the audible whatever you
you know prefer consuming there's lots
of great information in that go through
that chapter over and over again until
it's an extent the point needs to be
made quite clearly right you have a
limited amount of energy in a day to
dispense for things that should be
worthy of said energy
um I remember I mentioned spiders and I
just you know jotted out a no
because
my kids always like been afraid of
spiders it doesn't matter what I do it's
like dude like
you're way bigger than the bugs you
shouldn't be afraid of bugs she's afraid
of bugs it is what it is I'm not gonna
expend my energy killing spiders chasing
bugs around I got one of those
um
Dyson vacuums you know the rechargeable
ones that go on the wall with a long
neck and a pointy thing on the end she
just goes around sucking up spiders on
her own now so it's like I didn't want
to deal with it I saw a problem like
this you deal with it I'm not I'm not
lowering my myself I'm not taking my
energy level to things that don't
preserve my energy if you think that's
such a problem you deal with it so there
you go I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out